[Música]
con nuestra segunda invitada al día
vamos a hablar de cómo ha ganado terreno
la izquierda en América Latina tras el
triunfo en Brasil del ex presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula Silva y para ellos solo
Vamos a Ariel Ruiz caro economista
analista internacional investigadora de
el centro flaxo Gracias a Ariela por
estar con nosotros en directo América de
Franz 24 como ve América Latina sobre
todo pues los países que están dirigidos
no están gobernados por presidentes de
izquierda la llegada de Lula da Silva
nuevamente al poder
Buenos días gracias por la invitación
Bueno El Triunfo de Lula es algo
positivo para los gobiernos de izquierda
y yo diría para la región también que ha
tenido triunfos sucesivos desde Honduras
Perú Colombia chile en este año y y Lula
no el que yo creo que marca un liderazgo
en la región indudable es el país más
grande del continente latinoamericano no
Entonces por primera vez
convergen Argentina chile Argentina
[Música]
y Brasil y México y países como chile y
Colombia sobre todo Colombia que siempre
ha tenido una posición que ha puesto
señales de discordancia en la unasur a
pesar que la unasur fue un organismo que
tuvo una importancia muy
de la región pero que lamentablemente se
desactivó se puede digamos ver ahora una
especie de fortaleza de Unión en los
países del Sur en la mayoría de los
países del Sur con estos dirigentes de
izquierda Digamos como ellos pueden usar
esto a su favor no en pro del continente
en pro de las personas que habitamos
América del Sur
Sí yo creo que hay una gran oportunidad
para tener una posición más Autónoma y
soberana en la región por ejemplo en la
Cumbre de las Américas ya antes de la
elección de Lula los países son menos
digamos no siguen necesariamente las
políticas de Estados Unidos al no
haberse invitado a Cuba a Nicaragua y a
Venezuela a pesar de que todos son
miembros de la Cumbre de las de las
Américas
todos los países
rechazaron que no fueran invitados si
bien hay problemas que hay que resolver
en esos países esos deben resolverse en
el marco del organismo y para eso está
todos los países protestaron algunos lo
hicieron abiertamente y y de hecho esa
es una señal el otro tema es que por
ejemplo
ningún país todos los países
latinoamericanos han condenado la pero
ninguno ha aplicado sanciones económicas
salvo Colombia en tiempos de Uribe de
Duque de Iván Duque pero digamos por
ejemplo para la compra de las vacunas
América Latina no usó sus plataformas de
integración subregionales a pesar de que
las tienen para compra conjunta de
medicamentos nunca se pronuncien en
favor de prorrogarla la licencia de
propiedad intelectual de las vacunas
mientras durara la pandemia cosa que la
unión africana sí hizo ellos se
pronunciaron a favor de la propuesta de
indie Sudáfrica en el marco de la
Organización Mundial del Comercio de
liberar las patentes América Latina no
se pronunció yo creo que se viene un
momento en que van a
afinarse estas coincidencias porque
América Latina los países son los no
somos nada no lo representamos hemos
perdido presencia comercial presencia
diplomática y política en el en el juego
internacional claro Ariela digamos que
todo en papel le suena muy bonito y muy
viable Pero la realidad es que también
en todos estos años de repúblicas
recientes en nuestra América Latina ha
sido muy difícil tener una unidad una
coerción y digamos o puntos en común que
llevar adelante en todas nuestras
naciones no pareciera evidentemente que
sobre todo América del Sur por tener
ahora líderes de izquierda si se pudiera
encaminar como en algún momento
lo hizo lo intentó hacer la organización
de de mercosur pero en la realidad es en
las condiciones de hoy en día se puede
ver entonces pues esta Unión A lo mejor
como la que tiene la Unión Europea como
las que tiene la asean la que tiene
África porque en América Latina nunca se
termina realmente de hacer algo en
concreto
bueno América Latina ha tenido momentos
de unidad Como por ejemplo fue la unasur
donde se resolvieron varios conflictos
en
Bolivia hubo un intento de
independización del departamento de
Santa Cruz y la unasur intervino allí
luego en
Ecuador una revuelta policial durante el
gobierno de Correa y la unasur los
presidentes convocaron a una reunión
extraordinaria y se resolvió el problema
y luego cuando Estados Unidos instaló
bases militares en Colombia
los países latinoamericanos convocaron a
una reunión extraordinaria y todos los
presidentes asistieron a una cumbre en
Bariloche Argentina a preguntarle a
uriba hacer un interrogatorio de porque
se había permitido instalar bases
militares y América Latina además en los
60 en los 70 Tuvo una posición
importante y común en el movimiento de
los no alineados bastante más coherente
de lo que ha sido ahora entonces yo creo
que nos no tenemos otra salida No creo
que al estilo de la Unión Europea Porque
esos tiempos de formar un mercado común
una Unión aduanera ese tipo de
integración no es la que se pide para
América Latina sino una coordinación
cooperación política Empezando por la
política frente a temas diversos como
fue el tema de las vacunas por ejemplo
como es el tema del alineamiento frente
al conflicto de Ucrania con Rusia yo
creo que América Latina tiene que
condenar sí la guerra pero no puede
aplicar sanciones económicas porque ese
no es un conflicto de la región Entonces
por qué
autoinfligirnos un golpe como el que yo
creo que ha hecho Europa
frente a la guerra yo yo no estoy de
acuerdo con la posición que ha tomado
Europa necesariamente en seguir todas
las sanciones económicas porque el
inflige un daño a su población y de
hecho lo vemos en Francia Pero bueno no
es el tema de Europa sino América Latina
Claro
en la cooperación en la coordinación
política sobre denominadores comunes
mínimos
no tenemos otras salidas y creo que se
abre una oportunidad bueno Ariela Ojalá
que entonces la llegada de Lula da Silva
en un país tan importante la principal
economía de pues América Latina Brasil
pues se enfoque no a todos los gobiernos
que están a su alrededor en políticas
que funcionen para la población y que
realmente trabajan en pro de la economía
y en pro del surgimiento de nuestra
región de América Latina y el Caribe
haría la Muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros en directo
América de Francia 24 no no hay nada que
agradecer gracias a ustedes